Вот почему у умных людей часто не бывает
денег умный не значит богатый вы
замечали что умные люди часто не
достигают финансового успеха а богатые
не всегда умны я уверен что многие из
вас замечали это противоречие Так в чём
же Парадокс почему так происходит
досмотрите это видео до конца и вы
поймёте В чём секрет того почему умные
люди редко становятся богатыми и почему
для большого заработка не всегда нужен
острый ум подписывайтесь на мой канал
Ставьте лайк включайте уведомления чтобы
не пропустить ещё больше видео о том как
добиться успеха в жизни и бизнесе и
конечно же оставляйте свои комментарии
Давайте обсудим эту тему вместе Итак
поехали Парадокс умных и богатых людей
очень часто я встречаю людей которые
обладают действительно глубокими
знаниями и высоким интеллектом Ну к
сожалению они не могут похвастаться
значительными успехами в жизни в то же
время вокруг
когда я оглядываюсь вокруг меня полно
людей которые несмотря на отсутствие
особой интеллектуальной одарённости
достигли огромного финансового успеха в
чём подвох почему так
происходит Наблюдая за людьми и
Анализируя их действия я выявил причину
этого феномена Знаете она лежит в том
как люди реагируют на препятствия и
проблемы на своём пути к цели любой
успешный человек знает что цель не
достигается сразу на пути к ней
обязательно возникают какие-то
сложности и вот здесь начинаются самые
главные различия между теми кто
добивается успеха и теми кто увязать в
проблемах Напишите в комментариях под
этим видео то какие сложности вы
преодолели Как вы их решали Кстати вы
этим вдохновить многих людей и мне
самому будет интересно это почитать Как
действует богатые и успешные люди
давайте рассмотрим это богатые люди на
которых я ориентируюсь обладают
уникальной чертой они сфокусированы на
результате для них самое главное
достижение целей и они делают всё
возможное для этого когда они
сталкиваются с препятствием первое что
они делают они задаются
вопросом исследования показывают что
успешные люди имеют высокий уровень
социальной адаптации и
коммуникабельности что позволяет им
быстро находить нужных людей для решения
своих проблем профессор Ричард Ричард
вайзман из университета хартфордшира
например Изучая феномен удач и успеха
заметил что у богатых людей есть одна
определённая особенность они более
открыты к взаимодействию с другими
людьми и не боятся делегировать задачи
тем кто лучше справится с ними когда
успешные люди сталкиваются с проблемой
они не пытаются углубиться в её суть
сами и их подход очень прост Кто может
мне помочь это первый вопрос У всех
богатых людей Они ищут тех кто уже имеет
опыт в этой области или они просто
нанимают эксперта таким образом решение
проблемы оказывается быстрым и
эффективным и это позволяет им сохранить
фокус на главной цели не тратя время на
самостоятельное изучение И решение задач
в которых они не являются экспертами И
самое главное из-за высокой концентрации
на своий цели они даже не собираются
углубляться в том чтобы разобраться с
этой проблемой это э кстати черта очень
многих успешных людей которые я заметил
давно и Я даже заметил это по себе
Поэтому если вам интересно такие техники
такие инструменты и лайфхаки то
подписывайтесь на мой Telegram канал где
Я делюсь своими алгоритмами инсайта и
стратегиями а о том как вывести ваш
бизнес и вашу жизнь на новый уровень
ссылку на мой Telegram канал я оставлю в
описании к этому видео А как действуют
умные люди
Давайте теперь вспомним тех умных людей
которых мы знаем Ну для примера даже
вспомните своих одноклассников которые
там есть одноклассники У меня тоже были
такие которым легко давались все
предметы они всё схватывать на лету они
как правила редко усердно учились они
полагались на свою природную способность
быстро всё усваивать и благодаря этому у
них с детства с сформировалось такое
убеждение что они умны и они
переоценивают свой ум и считают это
своим главным достоинством Однако во
взрослой жизни именно эти люди эти
отличники можно сказать зачастую
сталкиваются с трудностями так вот когда
умный человек сталкивается с проблемой
его первый инстинкт изучить эту проблему
чувствуете разницу Да у успешного
человека первый инстинкт найти человека
которым быстро решит эту проблему а у
умного человека первый инстинкт изучить
её потому что он же считает что он умный
и может разбираться во всём сам для
умного человека любая проблема - это
интеллектуальный вызов они считают что
раз они уж умны они могут самостоятельно
разобраться с Любой задачей они знаете
как тот человек с молотком для которого
все проблемы кажутся
гвоздями Однако эта стратегия не всегда
работает в реальной жизни Я бы даже
сказал Она очень плохо работает в
реальной жизни исследования например
опубликованные в журнале
показали что люди с высоким I часто
склонны к переосмыслению и рати времени
на тщательный анализ проблемы Что может
замедлить их процесс в достижении целей
смотрите это данные исследования их эго
или уверенность в собственных
интеллектуальных способностях часто
мешает им спросить помощи или просить
Пох
с вместо того чтобы быстро продвигаться
к своей цели умные люди начинают
углубляться в изучение проблемы для них
это своего рода головоломка которую они
хотят решить самостоятельно то есть Они
получают Дофамин или
удовольствие не от преодоления
препятствия которое тормозит их и не
даёт достигнуть целей а от решения
задачи то есть само решение задачи и
этой проблемы для них является уже
вознаграждением они тратят огромное
количество времени на поиск решения
Забывая о главной цели и причём Я знаю
таких людей которые хотят не просто
найти решение а они хотят именно найти
красивое решение и на это тратится ещё
больше времени Если вы также попадали в
такую ситуацию когда вместо того чтобы
двигаться к цели решить проблему и
двигаться к цели вы начинали решать
проблему и
увязалась хочу посмотреть сколько нас
Вот давайте возьмём примеры жизни
представьте себе успешного бизнесмена
который столкнулся с какой-то проблемой
в своём бизнес Закройте глаза и мысленно
представьте себе своё окружение
наверняка среди вашего окружения есть
какой-то такой бизнесмен который не
слишком умный но у которого получается
делать бизнес так вот у него нет времени
и знаний чтобы решить проблему самому
вместо того чтобы углубляться в изучение
Новой темы он просто нанимает
специалиста который быстро решает ему
проблему и его бизнес Продолжает
двигаться дальше И кстати Если у вас
нету денег на то чтобы нанять классного
грамотного специалиста Либо вы у вас ещё
маленький бизнес или вы фрилансер или вы
работаете топ-менеджером И так далее
смотрите там есть такая трёхступенчатая
модель я это называю Первая это есть в
исламе такое правило не знаешь Спроси у
знающего поэтому обязательно посмотрите
ста
свой Круг людей с кем вы общаетесь и
Представьте кто уже решал аналогичную
проблему или кто может решить такую
проблему и попросите помощи у него на
втором этапе
уже постарайтесь спросить Это в
сообществе котором вы находитесь поэтому
Именно поэтому очень важно находиться в
каком-то сообществе профессиональном это
может быть клуб бизнесменов клуб
единомышленников какая-то ация группа
взаимной поддержки и так далее Спросите
там на третьем этапе постарайтесь у
какого-нибудь специалиста эксперта
просто попросить бесплатного совета И
кстати если вы не состоите в каком-либо
сообществе либо хотите найти сообщество
которое способствует и помогает
саморазвитию У меня есть Telegram а
Telegram канал А и В этом Telegram
канале я формирую сообщество вокруг тем
саморазвития лайфхаков и стратегии по
улучшению вашего бизнеса и вашей жизни
ссылку на свой Telegram канал я оставлю
в описании к этому видео а теперь
представьте себе умного человека который
сталкивается с такой же проблемой так
вот вместо того чтобы найти эксперта Он
решает сам изучить проблему тратит
недели а возможно и месяцы на то чтобы
разобраться с этим вопросом читает
статьи книги смотрит YouTube и так далее
За это время он теряет не только своё
время но и упускает возможности которые
мог бы привести его к успеху Почему
умные люди прои
чем умнее человек тем больше его эго
становится его преградой на пути к
успеху вместо того чтобы делегировать
задачи Или спросить совета умные люди
часто тратят Бесценное время на
самостоятельное решение проблеме для них
это вопрос престижа и доказательства
собственной компетентности это
опять-таки скажу к этому вет
эго и тут возникает е одна проблема пого
совершенством как я уже говорил об этом
ранее Они ищут не просто решение А
красивое решение исследования
проведённые профессором Барри шварцем
показали что люди с высоким уровнем
интеллекта склонны к
перфекционизм что затрудняет принятие
решений и мешает им двигаться вперёд вот
это вторая большая боль или проблема
всех умных людей они склонны к
перфекционизм
универсальная проблема всех людей - это
эго
эго заставляет нас думать что мы можем
справиться сами так вот у не слишком
умных людей эго находится ниже потому
что они понимают свои ограничения эго
мешает нам обращаться за помощью эго
замедляет наш
Прогресс поэтому запомните Чем ниже вы
будете держать своё эго тем больше вы
будете его контролировать тем больших
успехов вы добьётесь в жизни сила не в
том чтобы решить всё самому а в умении
находить правильных людей которые
помогут вам достичь вашей цели быстрее
вы
знаете в исламе есть такое высказывание
что берека даётся торговле
я долгое время думал почему берек
отдаётся в торговле а не в производстве
Там и так далее и я для себя понял одну
такую очень глубокую вещь что
оказывается торговля - это именно тот
вид деятельности который требует чтобы
человек контролировал своё эго Ведь
когда у вас есть Завод фабрика либо
скважина которая качает нефть Там и так
далее Вы можете производить товар и
продавать свой товар Ну то что
производите Да а вот чтобы быть
торговцем вы должны купить дёшево и
продать дорого и я не видел ни одного
торговца который был бы ТСН либо
горв все торговцы если пони всем
внимательны и пытаются услужить то есть
само занятие торговлей треть требует
контроля над своим эго Именно поэтому
барок отдаётся через торговлю именно
торговля учит вас управлять своим эго
даже если вы произвели какой-то товар
чтобы его продать вам нужно усмирить
своё эго и если вы хотите узнать как
работать со своим эго как держать под
контролем своё эго следите за моим выпу
Я обязательно сделаю видео на эту тему
поэтому подписывайтесь на мой канал
ставьте колокольчики и вы
обязательно дождётесь этого видео Итак
давайте подведём итог умные люди не
всегда успешны потому что они слишком
увлекаются своими проблемами и стремятся
решать их самостоятельно и причиной им
этому является то что они переоценивают
свой ум и их эго говорит ну зачем
кому-то обращаться если мы можем сами
решить этот вопрос успешные же люди
делают иначе они фокусируются на цели и
ищут тех кто поможет им двигаться вперёд
Поэтому если вы хотите добиться успеха
учитесь делегировать и не бойтесь
просить о помощи